[Music]
straight ahead
all law and crime daily the former
michigan governor charged in the flint
water crisis
wants his case dismissed the indictment
is fatally flawed
suspects in the storming of the u.s
capitol are looking towards the
president for their defenses
but will it hold up in court you can't
blame someone else
for your actions unless you have an
argument of duress
plus why police are thanking a florida
restaurant manager
with saving a boy's life and a
defendant's final words as he's
sentenced for his wife's murder
juan crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
attorneys for the former michigan
governor charged in the flint water
crisis
want his case thrown out
more than 80 people were sickened and 12
died after the city changed his drinking
water from a treated source
to the flint river in 2014. prosecutors
now say actions by government officials
were criminal
this case is about justice truth
accountability poisoned children lost
lives shattered families that are still
not whole
and simply giving a damn about all of
humanity
a grand jury indicted nine individuals
for a total of 42 counts
including former governor rick snyder
for two misdemeanors of willful neglect
and two former heads of the michigan
department of health and human services
for involuntary manslaughter
i did send a letter to uh solicitor
general fadwa hamoud
pointing out a number of things
including the fact that the indictment
is fatally flawed because it's
charged governor snyder with crimes
allegedly
that occurred in genesee county these
crimes which are
false but fatally flawed because they
charged in the wrong venue
at all times during the indictment
governor schneider was at his office in
uh
the romney building in downtown lansing
so the reason we held off we did file a
discovery request
but and we attached that letter to that
discovery request
but the reason we didn't file the motion
to dismiss is we're trying to give the
government
an opportunity to recognize this mistake
and voluntarily dismiss the indictment
against governor snyder scientists
learned lead from aging pipes
leaked into the city's water supply the
possible source of a deadly legionnaires
disease outbreak
the grand jury proceedings are secret
but prosecutors say their team reviewed
millions of documents
and hundreds of electronic devices
frankly and there's other because this
is a
unique process by which these charges
were brought to
um discovery there's some other issues
with regarding to
discovery that i think we need to
discuss uh with defense council as well
frankly anticipated a motion uh pursuant
to mcr
6.107 because this indictment was issued
pursuant to a grand jury but i haven't
seen that yet but
yes for purposes of today your honor
we're just asking for another court date
so that we can observe
and respond to defendant's motion to
dismiss
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney eckland mercy along with terry
austin
eckland so far snyder's defense sounds
i'm sorry
kind of laughable he can't be charged in
that county because he wasn't there at
the time of the harm
how do you see this case working out for
him well it just
it started off wrong it just it badly
reflects on the attorneys because snyder
actually has an mba and a jd so he
should have a simple grasp
of what venue is and how he could be
charged for the crime
because he was a whole governor so um i
think it was just the plot sometimes you
just have to file stuff to file stuff
i think that they knew that it wasn't
going to be successful but it sucks that
they did it anyway
yeah you can be in one county and do
something that harms another person and
they can drag you into court
where the person's harmed it makes total
sense terry the foot water crisis
was and still is a huge issue do you
think anyone's gonna be serving serious
jail time though
you know i hope that someone does serve
serious jail time because these are
serious crimes i mean
the former chief of health he was
actually charged with nine counts
of involuntary manslaughter which you
know is
punishable up to 15 years in prison and
if governor snyder
is convicted he too could get up to a
year in jail so these are serious crimes
there are others who were charged
and i do think that they should be
punished and held accountable for their
crimes
yeah this will likely not be a simple
slap on the wrist eklyn terry thank you
very much
turning now to other top news and
celebrities making headlines
music producer and convicted murderer
phil spector died while serving his
prison sentence
spectre is known for his wall of sound
recording and work with musicians like
the beatles and tina turner
specter was found guilty of
second-degree murder in 2009
for the shooting death of actress lana
clarkson he was represented at his first
trial by criminal defense attorney
and law and crime host linda kenny
bodden a spokesperson for the department
of corrections
says spectre died of natural causes
husband to actress laurie lachlan
massimo gianouli is seeking an emergency
release from prison
attorneys for the fashion designers says
his eight weeks in solitary confinement
are extreme punishment giannoli is
currently serving a five-month sentence
for his role in the college admissions
scandal lachlan was released at the end
of december
giannoli is scheduled to be released in
april his attorneys are asking a judge
to allow him to serve the rest of his
time at home still ahead on law and
crime daily a restaurant manager
credited with rescuing a boy from abuse
but first our experts take on the
possible defense of suspects in the
storming
of the u.s capitol building
[Music]
a number of people facing charges in the
riot at the capitol are asking for
pardons
and they say they were following the
orders of the president
president trump angela levy looked into
whether the claim or
defense would hold up in court
yeah brian we're going to call this the
trump told me to do it defense
there have been people asking for
pardons some actually saying they were
following the directions of the
commander-in-chief so they should be off
the hook
but when it comes to defending a case in
a courtroom this likely is not going to
work
droves of people forced their way into
the u.s capitol
others appeared to walk through
practically invited
riley williams is accused of stealing
nancy pelosi's laptop
and texas realtor jenna ryan says she
deserves a pardon
because she was doing what the president
wanted her to do
is it a defense that could work they
can't say that
the president states ordered me to do
that that's that's not going to fly
this is not the military even though he
is the commander-in-chief
former federal prosecutor gene rossi
says the trump told me to do it defense
is a non-starter you can't blame someone
else
for your actions unless you have an
argument of
duress the attorney for jacob chansley
also known as the q anon
shaman questioned his client's mental
state on law and crime daily
it doesn't take much to look at my
client and say you know what
maybe just maybe he doesn't fall within
the bell curve
of that which you and i would consider
normal whether chansley is so mentally
ill that it impacted his actions that
day is a question
yet to be answered rossi believes those
who organize the event on january
6th could be in a lot of legal trouble i
think the president united states donald
trump
faces serious criminal liability i think
he really does
and gene rossi believes that president
trump's personal lawyer rudy giuliani
and also
people who organized that rally on
january 6
could also face some criminal exposure
brian
and each day we see more and more people
identified and charged
what about those who appear to walk in
after the doors were already open
yeah that's a that's a really good
question because some of those people as
we mentioned in the piece look like they
were just kind of walking through
and some were even maybe allowed in by
some of the police officers at least it
appeared that way from some of the
videos that we saw
gene rossi calls those the lemmings you
know the people that were just trickling
in afterward he thinks they will have a
better chance
of arguing that maybe they made a
mistake and maybe they could have a
better
chance of defending themselves but those
people who were
forcing their way in with force breaking
windows damaging property he said they
are going to have a very tough road to
hoe
thanks angenette here with me to break
down the defenses are attorneys eklund
mercy and terry austin eklund
this hole the president told me to or to
do it or invited me or i was just
walking in
does that sound like a strong argument
the only argument they have or do you
see some success in it
oh they're gonna win because they're
white um the issue is it's gonna work
because they're white
listen i know what i saw there was
treason
now if uh you know black people get
treated differently
if my black were to do what they did
it wouldn't work i wouldn't be here the
issue is is that when you're white you
can make mistakes
you can have you can use the defense of
duress when you are black you're
supposed to have
the patience of job and the wisdom of
solomon
at every given point in time the
unfortunate reason is that history will
tell you
what will happen they will not get
prosecuted
they will say that because um the the
the pain that they've had in the in
you know what they've had in the media
the the
the flinging of the mud in the media is
enough
and then they will issue their sad
apology their sorry apology
and they'll be free to micro aggress um
other people for the rest of their days
that's what um the history tells us and
that's what i'm expecting to happen
so terry eklund says that she doesn't
even think there's going to be a full
prosecution but
talking about some of these arguments it
kind of academically makes sense the
president
the president can invite me into the
capitol the president can invite me to
any restricted area but do you think
that will make sense here
and if not why well it should not make
sense here brian
the argument that these individuals were
invited to the capitol by the president
and allowed into the premises by the
police
is a bunch of malarkey i mean
trespassing destroying property
insurrection these are all very serious
crimes
ignorance of the law has never ever been
a defense
and blindly following others who are
breaking the law
is also not a defense whether or not
they're prosecuted we will see
but my hope is that each of these
individuals
is prosecuted to the fullest extent of
the law because these are serious crimes
and we need to hold them accountable
yeah like i said every day we're seeing
more and more arrests and of course
we'll keep you up to date on those
arrests and those defenses
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily a family calls out a
convicted killer
in court plus
the note that saved the child from years
of abuse hear from the woman behind it
after the break
police in orlando florida are crediting
a restaurant manager with helping to
save the life
of a severely abused 11 year old boy
the boy was the night food the man
told me that no that was everything okay
and the boy was okay and he was
gonna have his uh dinner at the night
at home this uh was super strange to me
and when i looked to the boy and i saw a
really a big scratch between his
uh eyebrows and
i started observing them and i
could saw that he was super quiet
and said i wrote another sign
asking him if he needs help and
he nodded his head yes
the manager then went to the back of the
restaurant to call 9-1-1
officers quickly arrived on the scene to
investigate
the child came forward with some
statements
the father was then arrested on a child
abuse charge
and was transported to orange county
jail the
child was then transported to the
hospital
where the department of children and
families made contact
additional allegations of abuse
were discovered and that's where
the special victims unit came in we took
over the investigation from there
and based on the new allegations that we
discovered
the father was then arrested again with
three counts of aggravated child abuse
and a
count of child neglect and the child's
mother was also arrested on two counts
of child neglect
for her failure to act and failure to
protect the 11 year old child
back for analysis our defense attorneys
eclin mercy and terry austin
eckland i get we have to use the legal
term abuse but this child based on what
i understand was tortured
by his stepfather and the mother allowed
it she knew what was going on
can you talk to us about what that
mother could face in terms of charges
even though she might not have put hands
on this child
well real quick you have to give it up
for the real hero here and that's the
child
do you understand how hard it was for
him to nod his head
he's been abused so he was just you know
used to it and
for him to be able to accept help was so
was so admirable and we have to
acknowledge that
it's very hard for a child to do an
outcry so we have to
acknowledge that with regards to the
mother you don't just
um you know get into a an abusive
relationship there's probably some
history
there's probably some things in her
background that we need to see
we won't know until a full investigation
is done
until that child has a forensic
evaluation we don't know what type of
wounds
that um that they're going to uncover
that you know
will will actually correlate with
criminal charges
so at you know neglect is at the least
but she can have a good defense
meaning that she's you know she's a
victim of abuse as well
exactly now terry kind of looking to the
hero the manager here
quick thinking saved i think a child's
life here this could have ended
horribly if it wasn't for this manager
what are your thoughts
i could not agree with you more brian
this woman was not only a good samaritan
like you said
she was a hero you know all too often we
hear about cases in the system
where the system has failed and the
child was not only abused but the child
was
killed at the hands of their parents or
their caretakers
and here we have someone who actually
saw something
and said something and it's a reminder
to all of us that we need to stay
vigilant and we need to protect
our children absolutely thank you so
much for this manager who was there and
of course as eklund said i want to echo
that
the child is also the hero here for
being able to nod his head because
while it might be a small thing for you
and i to do this after what i can only
imagine
years of abuse that's a huge huge heroic
effort on his end thank you both
when we come back hiro defended himself
as he admits to killing his wife
and fleeing driving clear across the
country
a florida man will spend the next 38
years in prison for murdering his wife
and later telling police where her body
was
gretchen anthony was reported missing in
march after her blue mini cooper was
found in a hospital parking lot
in jupiter florida her husband david
anthony
fled a week later police arrested him
across the country in new mexico
cadaver dogs alerted to areas in the
couple's home and the defendant's nissan
frontier
but they were unable to locate a body
that is
until anthony agreed to plead guilty to
charges of second-degree murder
and kidnapping in a deal that spared him
the death penalty
investigators found remains they believe
are gretchen anthony her cause of death
is still pending i disgraced my family
i'm hated by some beyond words and it
brought
shame upon my name
some would call for my death and i can't
offer any reasonable argument against
that symptom
all i can offer is acknowledgement of my
actions and unfair forgiveness
for my loss of self-control for allowing
my paranoia
greed and addiction to drive the scene
aside
then lived by their illusions and my
vision saw the copenhagen against an end
of the world
prophecy an armageddon that i felt
compelled to escape
no matter the cost when action becomes
attached from consequences
that's what madness occurs my addiction
to
the disintegrated marijuana combined
with untreated mental health issues
further fuel change reaction or lead
from one tragic event to the next
the defendant's family asked for
leniency citing his mental health issues
and a bipolar diagnosis the victim's
family said he's a monster
what happened to gretchen is truly
horrific and has left us with deep
sadness to the defendant whose name
and being are not worthy of the air we
all breathe
your statement will never mean anything
to anyone you are a fraud gretchen had a
huge
heart and saved your life
when your car fell on you yet you killed
gretchen in that same garage where she
saved your life
then instead of confessing to the cruel
murder
that you committed you used what you did
to negotiate something for yourself
you are pure evil you stole
a mother away from her child a daughter
away from her mother a sister
away from my brother and me
back one last time for analysis are our
experts echo i'm kind of torn here on
one end i
want criminal defendants who are going
to admit to these crimes
to have an incentive to say hey this is
where the body is and maybe even we can
save some lives
on the other side though do we want to
have that
as a rule that hey we'll lessen your
jail time if you give us this amount of
information
how do you think this should play out
across the country um
well i i think with this particular
situation i am opposed to the death
penalty so i think that it's the win
but for real we're actually looking at
the victims families
you know closure is priceless and you
know so if if the family is okay with
the deal
run upon the plea because what you don't
want to do is be emotionally
like go through the emotional
waterboarding that is trial trial prep
with the possibility that this person
may be free because you don't
have the real story so i mean although
it seems like it's not
although it seems unfair but they got
that closure they can
begin to heal now so i think that that's
what you have to look at it from the
victim's family perspective and i think
that you know it worked out
yeah terry eckland i again that's part
of the main reason why i support this
and also the death penalty is off the
table
we're looking at it from a victim
standpoint of closure and helping them
get through this
do you think this was the right call by
the prosecutor and the judge
well in this case it was from the
victim's standpoint i think they
wanted to have the closure so i agree
with eclin but i understand that but i
think this
sort of deal sends the wrong message to
killers that
their lives will be spared if they agree
to lead the police to the body so i
think we have to be
careful when we have those types of
deals being made with defendants and you
know here
the family said that he had mental
illness but there was no
evidence of mental illness in the trial
itself so
i think that they could have stuck with
the death penalty here
whether you agree with it or not i think
that perhaps
it might have been the right thing here
and we should not be negotiating
if you give me the body then i'll give
you you know i'll spare your life
all right so maybe it's a case-by-case
situation maybe it's great here because
again
this is what the family wanted if we're
looking at a victim
forward perspective we'll see how this
plays out eckland terry thank you for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here on the law and crime daily we'll
see you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you